let's see NBC has this report U.S
doctors should regularly screen all
adults under 65 for anxiety and
influential Health guidelines group
proposed on Tuesday
it's the first time the U.S preventive
Services Task Force has recommended
anxiety screening and primary care for
adults without symptoms
The Proposal is open for public comments
until October 17th
but the group usually affirms its draft
Guidance the recommendations are based
on a review that began before the
covid-19 pandemic evaluating studies
showing potential benefits and risks
from screening given reports of a surge
in mental health problems linked with
pandemic isolation and stress the
guidance is very timely says Lori Bert a
task force member and co-author
actually your name is pronoun name is
spelled p b e r t Bert is that what it
is pbert is a psychologist researcher at
the University of Massachusetts Chan
medical school
so this is what they're recommending now
uh and this and they're recommending it
and the recommendations always always
end up um
becoming policy so this is going to be
the policy now we're going to do anxiety
screenings for adults without symptoms
and it's the kind of thing that I think
if you're not really clued in and paying
attention you might hear that and you
might say well it sounds like a good
idea sure extreme anxiety is a bad thing
and why not have a doctor screen for it
this is actually a terrible idea this is
an awful idea
because I tell you what this functions
as and I tell you what the purpose of it
is it is to funnel more and more people
into the pharmaceutical pipeline get
more and more people on drugs they want
to fight like we don't have enough
people on psychotropic drugs already we
don't have enough people on anti-anxiety
antidepressants already
even though with antidepressants the
whole the the the the the medical basis
for antidepressants has been destroyed
now it's been revealed to be a fraud but
still you know millions of people on
these drugs not enough though for the
system they want even more people and so
now they're gonna they're gonna start
screening you for anxiety symptoms
so they find a hint of anxiety they can
say well let's get him on a drug too
good news you get to be on a drug
screening for anxiety symptoms
everyone has anxiety it is The Human
Condition it is one of the most
uh
it's it's it is a Hallmark of The Human
Condition in fact there's anxiety it's
one of the things that separates us from
the animals
it's one of the defining traits of the
human psyche is anxiety
everyone has it every single person you
right now every single person watching
you all have anxiety all of you like
there's never been a person who has
walked through a day and not experienced
anxiety it has never happened ever in
the history of humanity
and so now if we're screening everyone
for it on a regular basis that means
that what do you know we're gonna we're
gonna find millions of more cases of
anxiety and that's millions of uh more
customers for the pharmaceutical
industry
and not just funneling them into the
clutches of the pharmaceutical industry
but also into the clutches of therapists
and counselors
um which is a problem
as well because although in theory
therapy and counseling can be a good
thing I mean the whole idea between
behind therapies you go and you talk to
someone you talk about your problems in
theory that's a very good thing and
there are very good therapists and
counselors out there
but a lot of them are rabid ideologues
and gender ideology cultists with their
own agenda
and their agenda has nothing to do with
act with anything therapeutic they're
not looking to help you with your
problems
so for example here's a viral Tick Tock
posted by Libs of tech talk well
reposted she didn't post it initially
um
this is from a therapist
and this is a tick tock that he posted
and this is what therapy is today in so
many cases so we'll play it and we'll
read the captions up here but go ahead
and play it
so it says point of view your homophobic
transphobic parents drop you off to
therapy thinking I'm a hetero
and he starts dancing
me Queer as F here to validate your
feelings support you talk about
oppression and challenge your parents
then this is again something you post
willingly to tick tock for everyone to
see
so he says here's what he's actually
here to do go put the back up on the
screen for a second
the end of that
what he's actually here to do
so the parents drop the kids off
thinking that well am I going to get my
kids therapy may they need some help
they have emotional problems makes sense
as a parent you'd like to think that you
that you could trust a therapist but he
says no that's not his agenda is not
that his agenda is because he's queer as
f is to validate your feelings support
you talk about oppression and challenge
your parents
that is not therapy that is not
counseling
uh validating your feelings
is is the not just not therapy that's
the opposite of what a therapist is
supposed to do
if the patient is going to sit down
there and um the client is going to sit
down there and you're going to validate
whatever they say why are they there
what are you there for what's the
function exactly
oh they're not supposed to be there to
validate whatever unreasonable
delusional
thing you might think
to validate your in a firm your lack of
perspective your confusions they're
supposed to be there for clarity
and perspective
and if a child isn't getting along with
his parents
the therapist is supposed to help heal
that relationship
help the child see more clearly help the
child understand his feelings and his
his thoughts
and help to heal the Divide between
parent and child
but now for so many of these people as
they will willingly announce for
everyone to see
they see their job as the opposite their
job is to sever the parent-child
relationship destroy it
and to take all of the mental confusion
that's causing the problem and um
encourage it
and there's going to be more victims as
we as we start screening people for
anxiety and depression and all these
other things uh that that means sending
them more into therapists and then what
happens
so someone gets screened maybe your kid
gets a little anxiety screening and the
doctor says yep got some anxiety let's
get him on drugs send him to a therapist
sits down with a therapist and the
therapist says well you know I've
figured out what your anxiety is all
about turns out that uh well you think
you're a boy but you're actually a girl
that's what the anxiety is
and your parents will tell you otherwise
don't listen to them they're a bunch of
scumbags and they're oppressive and
bigoted don't listen to them
this is the process
this is how you trans an entire
generation which is what they're doing
right now
well I hope you enjoyed that clip from
Matt wall show if you did be sure to
subscribe to this YouTube channel and
click the notification button to get
more content like this if you want to
watch or listen to the full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe today you
can also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts